les entraîneurs en kilt c'était l'image
insolite de ce samedi 23 février au
stade robert barran de plaisir le club
écossais de glasgow est venu affronter
sur le terrain une équipe composée de
joueurs locaux dans le cadre d'un
partenariat créé en parallèle du tournoi
des six nations
sur le terrain les français l'emportent
38 à 24
on a beau faire la fête la veille sur le
terrain il ya pu y a plus d'amitié
pendant deux fois quarante minutes
donc bon match c'était un match très dur
aujourd'hui il beaucoup d'essais pour
les deux équipes très agréable très dur
beaucoup de joueurs ont été en
difficulté aujourd'hui mais nous allons
passer un bon moment après deux matches
ce rendez-vous est également l'occasion
pour les français de comparer leur jeu à
celui des écossais je dirais engagé et
mobile c'est des joueurs assez mobile
assez léger et qui se déplace beaucoup
donc voilà c'est pas comme le jeu
français où on a plus plus l'habitude
d'avoir d'avoir des gros de fixer là
c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus rapide
ça joue sajou énormément ce partenariat
organisé pour la première fois plaisir a
convaincu les dirigeants du club c'est
bien parce que ça va je pense qu'on peut
développer des échanges ne serait ce
qu'avec aller une fois tous les deux ans
donc c'est ce qui se passe avec leur
entente là peut même prévoir d'y aller
avec des jeunes minimes des cadets une
bonne expérience pour rencontrer
d'autres cultures
après avoir déjeuné ensemble les joueurs
sont ensuite allés voir le match du
quinze de france face aux quinze du
chardon stade de france et là aussi les
français l'ont emporté
à